the truth is when producers wanted me to  be sexy but always with some absurd spin  on it that made me feel like I was still  in control  [Applause]  [Music]  what happened in the last five years  real fans probably knew deep down and  there was something going on  paranoia fear body pain xiety I go  everywhere touching me all day and  talking at me all day total silence and  all these people will leave and then  I'll be alone I didn't feel good enough  and I do now that's the good part  I have chased this for five years but  when I feel the adrenaline of my music  and my fans I can't [ __ ] duck  my family is the most important thing in  my life she's 19 I can always bring my  past with me but I can never go back you  got to leave yourself behind  [Music]  I want to do the opposite with our  realistics I'm going to do there really  isn't anything better than this  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  lady gaga  oh do we tell them  [Music]  you